Endlich geht es los:
Morgen fährt der Zug,
und Maya wird mit ihrer Freundin
ihre erste Interrail-Reise machen.
Vier Wochen ohne Eltern stehen an.
Das kommt mit,
das ziehe ich morgen an.
Das ziehe ich morgen an.
Es ist nass.
- Ist es noch nass?
Es ist feucht.
Steck es in den Tumbler!
- Nein, trocknen lassen.
Ich stecke es in den Tumbler.
- Nein.
Okay, ich habe zu viel Kleidung.
Ich muss mich entscheiden.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier ..
... fünf, sechs.
Sieben. Sieben Oberteile. Acht.
Aber einen Pulli mit Kapuze oder so?
Falls es windig ist.
Der ist aber mega schwer.
- Für abends.
Der Pulli?
- Ja.
Ich nehme sicher keinen Pulli mit.
Nimmst du die Tasche mit?
- Ich weiss noch nicht.
Ich nehme nichts Langärmeliges mit.
Im schlimmsten Fall werde ich sagen:
"Mama hatte recht."
Mama hat immer recht!
- Nein.
Francesca ist Mayas Reisepartnerin.
Ich gehe in die Ferien!
* Hüpfende elektronische Musik *
* Sie lacht. *
Ihr Freund Jonas
muss zu Hause bleiben.
Er spürt,
dass du nicht mehr lange hier bist.
Ja.
Ah, Gott!
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das alles reinpasst.
Ja, ja.
Die längste Zeit,
die wir getrennt waren ...
Mein Spitalaufenthalt.
... ohne einander zu sehen,
waren nicht einmal 24 Std.
Das tut uns sicher auch gut.
Das geht schon.
Dein Blick sagt: "Nein!"
Unterwegs mit Interrail.
Der Typ dort sagte,
wir hätten ihn soeben verpasst.
Ein Liebespaar ...
Man fühlt sich wie zu Hause.
... vier beste Kumpels ...
Wien ist easy cool.
- V.a. mit euch.
Francesca, wie soll die Perspektive
sein? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
... und zwei Freundinnen
reisen einen Monat lang mit dem Zug
von Abenteuer zu Abenteuer.
Sind sie gleich gross?
Wir können einen Gruppenchat machen
und Fotos schicken.
Machen wir das! Dann müsst ihr nicht
alles dreimal schicken.
Wir werden sowieso schreiben.
(Vater) Das musst ihr tun,
sonst suche ich euch.
Oh, come on!
Tschüss, Papi!
Maya und Francesca
kennen sich schon lange.
Sie singen beide im Chor und
lieben es, gemeinsam Musik zu machen.
Beide ernähren sich vegan -
das schweisst sie noch mehr zusammen.
Wir hören uns.
Jö.
Mein Papi:
"Vermisse dich!"
Soll ich gleich den Chat einrichten,
damit er beruhigt ist?
Das ist gut.
Du kannst ja schreiben:
"Keine Angst, wir leben noch."
Genau!
Ich war noch nie in Mailand.
Deshalb ist das unser erster Stopp.
- Ja, voll.
Obwohl, ich habe nicht
so hohe Erwartungen.
Es ist sicher schön,
aber das Einzige, wovon ich weiss,
ist der Dom, den jeder Mensch,
der in Mailand ist,
auf seine Story packt.
- Ja, genau.
Genau das will ich
eben provokativ nicht machen.
Oh mein Gott,
mit dem Rucksack muss man aufpassen,
dass man nichts kaputt macht.
Wie wär's mit Keksen?
Die Frage ist,
ob es vegane Kekse gibt.
Francesca.
Willst du ...
... mein Travel Buddy sein
für die nächsten 30 Tage?
Ich will!
Nur für die nächsten 30 Tage?
Fürs ganze Leben.
Endlich geht es los.
Ich sehe David.
Muss jemand noch aufs WC?
- Ich war schon.
Die vier Berner Jungs
sind seit fünf Jahren
beste Kumpels und eine feste Clique.
Auf ihrer Interrail-Reise
wollen sie v.a. Spass haben
und ihre Freundschaft feiern.
Schöne Ferien.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Schöne Ferien.
- Dir auch.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Äh ...
Bern-Wien.
- Erster ...
Ich kann so nicht schön schreiben.
Sollen wir nochmals rauswinken?
* Lachen *
So.
- Jetzt geht's los!
Kein Zurück mehr.
Luc, Luca und David ziehen
nach der Reise gemeinsam in eine WG.
Oh, wir müssen Geisser fragen,
ob wir eine Katze haben können.
Du weisst aber schon,
dass ich allergisch bin?
Es ist ja meine Katze
und nicht deine.
Du musst sie ja nicht anfassen.
Aber ...
Eine junge Katze?
- Kann sie schon sprechen?
Ich fände es voll easy.
Du willst also eine Katze?
- Ich bekomme eine.
Das ist schon fix?
Das höre ich zum ersten Mal.
So ist es praktisch.
- Sehr.
Die Interrail-Reise ist auch ein Test
für das spätere WG-Leben.
Und dann noch Haare schneiden.
Das machen wir noch schnell.
Ich bestelle ein Uber.
Kannst du einen grossen bestellen?
In Wien übernachten die vier Jungs
für wenig Geld
in einer Airbnb-Wohnung.
Jetzt können die Ferien beginnen!
Wenn wir schon in Wien sind ...
- Jonny 5?
Nein, "Vienna Calling" von Falco.
Also, Paprika,
Tafelsalz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer weiss.
Kno... Knoblauch.
Curry und Paprika edelsüss.
Unser Paar, Deborah und Arthur,
ist seit sechs Monaten zusammen.
Überleg dir: Was sind die drei
unnötigsten Dinge, die drin sind?
Es ist alles schon ziemlich ...
Ja?
Echt?
Sie reisen auf der Suche
nach Abenteuer und Wildnis
mit Zelt, Campingkocher
und Schlafsack.
Freiheit auf Schienen.
Nice.
(Durchsage) Grüze.
Deborah ist 18 und hat vor Kurzem
die Matura bestanden.
Arthur arbeitet bereits als Fotograf
und studiert nebenbei Fotografie
an der Kunstschule in Zürich.
Oh, damn.
- Was ist das?
Eine Schlinge.
- Das ist eine Falle.
Damit kann man Tiere jagen.
Okay, wir müssen
eine Schlinge machen.
"Durchgänge seitwärts blockieren
mit losem Geäst."
"Schlingen. Durchgänge ..."
Ich will das eigentlich nicht.
- Es sieht sehr tödlich aus.
Wir müssen die M1 nehmen, die Metro.
Aber das ist S1.
Warte, ich kriege noch Wechselgeld.
Wir müssen dort runter.
- Es steht, S1 in diese Richtung.
Aber wir müssen nicht S1.
- Ist es M1?
Sicher?
- Ja.
So, auch wenn es nur zwei Stationen
sind, setzen wir uns.
M2 ist in diese Richtung.
Ich glaube, es ist hier.
Ich verstehe es so,
dass M2 hier ist.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch weiter.
Ah, nein.
Heute haben wir Handys
und können alles nachschauen.
Aber was hat man früher
auf Reisen gemacht?
Man benötigte viel mehr Zeit und war
wahrscheinlich weniger gestresst.
Seit den Prüfungen bin ich so müde.
Jetzt kommt die Müdigkeit.
Vorher nicht?
- Ich habe es weggeschoben.
So konnte ich lernen.
Alles war Stress, Stress, Stress.
Jetzt ist der Stress weg und ...
Ich war noch nie in einem Hostel.
- Noch nie?
Boah, ich schwitze gerade
wie verrückt.
Ich bin froh,
wenn ich das Pyjama anhabe.
Wow, mega eindrücklich.
Sheesh!
Francesca möchte unbedingt
Tierärztin werden.
Vor der Reise hat sie
die Aufnahmeprüfung
fürs Medizinstudium abgelegt.
Machst du ein Foto mit mir drauf?
Wir können gemeinsam eins machen,
aber so weiss ich, von wo.
Francesca, wie soll die Perspektive
sein? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Thank you so much.
Die beiden Freundinnen
lieben Tiere über alles
und ernähren sich deshalb vegan.
Hoi.
Jetzt haut sie wieder ab.
Oh-oh!
Jö.
So niedlich.
Das ist so sister goals.
Ich finde die Kinder
fast niedlicher als die Katzen.
Ich auch.
Gibt es auch ein Kindercafe?
Ich bin wirklich froh,
dass die Prüfungen vorbei sind.
Ah, ich konnte den ganzen Stress
von mir abfallen lassen.
Ich hoffe, ich bestehe.
- Ja!
Und wenn nicht, würde ich es
nächstes Jahr wieder versuchen.
Ich will unbedingt
Tieren helfen können.
Mega.
- Ja, ich sehe dich in dieser Rolle.
Ob sie die Aufnahmeprüfung
bestanden hat,
wird Francesca wohl
unterwegs erfahren.
Aha, sie fährt nicht ganz bis ...
Dann steigen wir doch einfach
bei der Donauinsel aus.
Dort am Fluss.
Gehen wir doch dort an den Fluss.
Mir ist eigentlich
schon Zürich zu gross.
Oh, schau mal,
dort unten schwimmt einer!
Das ist viel spannender.
Okay,
die Donauinsel hätten wir abgehakt.
* Deborah lacht. *
Ich frage mich, was dort vorne
kommt, wenn man weitergeht.
Hm ...
Ich frage mich nicht so sehr.
Vielleicht sind wir nicht
für grosse Städte gemacht.
Grosse Städte sind ...
- Wir latschen einfach rum.
"Was sollen wir machen?"
Wenn wir im Zentrum sind,
suchen wir immer einen Park,
wenn wir im Zug sind,
fahren wir aufs Land.
Wieso zwingen wir uns,
in eine Grossstadt zu gehen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, all diese
Gärten sind einfach flacher Rasen.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwo
einen abenteuerlichen Wald.
Mhm.
Wir sind hier.
Und all das ist Wald.
Wow, ich hab's mir
anders vorgestellt.
Dort hinten sieht es waldig aus.
- Aha!
Dort am Berg.
- Ich hätte eher gesagt, hier.
Nur weil du ein paar Bäume siehst.
* Beschwingte osteuropäische Musik *
Die vier Jungs sind alle Anfang 20.
Wien ist sehr schön.
Wien ist easy cool.
V.a. mit euch.
(Mit Wiener Akzent)
Kommt's herein!
Elias studiert in Yverdon
und David ist gelernter Koch.
Luc ist zurzeit im Zivildienst
und Luca beginnt nach der Reise
sein Sportmanagementstudium.
So muss
ein Wiener Schnitzel aussehen.
Es ist mega gut.
* Beschwingte Akkordeonmusik *
Danach sehe ich aus
wie aus der Werbung.
Du hast das wirklich
schon mal gemacht?
Ja, ich habe Lukas
sogar schon den Schnauz gefärbt.
Wow.
Anspruchsvoll.
Ist es schlimm, wenn ich so Zeugs
in den Haaren habe? Zu spät!
Es brennt in den Augen.
Diese Flecken gehen nicht mehr weg.
Bleichflecken?
- Ja.
Das wird lustig aussehen.
Gut, nicht lustig.
Wird das gut aussehen?
- Sicher.
Hast du ganz unten auch?
- Ja.
Na gut, let's fetz!
Zeig mal!
Holy shit!
Wie hübsch auf einer Skala
von Eins bis Justin Bieber?
Oh!
Lacht nicht so blöd!
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ein Plastiksack besser wäre.
Wir stülpen einen Sack drüber.
- Drüber?
Schön.
Sehr, sehr schön.
Das ist richtig geil.
Komm auch, Luc!
Ich komme auch.
- Das war knapp.
* Freudenruf *
Hatte ich nicht mal eine Mütze?
* Temporeiche elektronische Musik *
Ah.
Meine Stimme flattert so.
Die nächste Station
von Maya und Francesca ist Genua.
Dort machen sie zum ersten Mal
Couchsurfing.
Sie übernachten
bei wildfremden Menschen.
(Englisch)
* Fröhliche Musik:
"I'm Yours" von Jason Mraz *
(Italienisch)
# Before the cool done run out
I'll be giving it my best.
# And nothing's going to stop me
but divine intervention.
# I reckon it's again my turn
to win some or learn some.
# But I won't hesitate no more,
no more.
# It cannot wait, I'm sure.
# There's no need to complicate.
Our time is short.
# This is our fate, I'm yours.
Oha!
Einfach nicht über meine Kleider.
- Wieso ist das voll?
Ich glaube, da war Eis drin.
Es ist geschmolzen.
Iih!
- Das ist nur Eis.
Das ist sicher nicht mehr gut.
Alles ist nass.
Sie sind auf härteren Alk
umgestiegen.
Eine haben sie gekillt
und die andere ...
Igitt!
Das ist voll weird.
Das ist aufgeklebt.
- Ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Weird.
Das ist wie Tetris.
Er ist wach. Hello.
Hi.
- Hi.
Hai mal di testa?
Genova.
Bis ... Riomaggiore.
2 Std. Easy.
* Vogelzwitschern, Verkehrslärm *
(Englisch)
Oh, wow.
Weg aus der Grossstadt
und ab nach Slowenien, in die Natur.
Wie spät ist es?
Wir sollten langsam ...
Es ist punkt 12 Uhr.
Um 12.25 Uhr fährt er.
Jetzt ist schon 12 Uhr?
Wir müssen los.
- Und zwar sehr schnell.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass es schon so spät ist.
* Helle, hüpfende Klänge *
Ich komme so nicht vorwärts.
Schwierig.
Excuse me.
Ich habe von Kollegen gehört,
die sagten:
"Weisst du, du hast eine Freundin,
das ist super."
"Dann musst du dich nicht mehr
so darum kümmern, wie du aussiehst."
"Du musst am Morgen
die Haare nicht machen."
Das ist wirklich lustig.
Deswegen gehen vielleicht
so viele Beziehung kaputt.
Am Anfang
präsentieren sie sich ganz anders,
dann sind sie in der Beziehung
und haben das Gefühl,
sie müssen das nicht mehr tun.
Dann kommt das wahre Ich
zum Vorschein.
Ich sehe nicht ein, wieso so viele
Menschen eine Beziehung eingehen
für ein paar Monate oder so,
im Bewusstsein ...
Sie könnten sich ...
Ich finde,
man muss sich vorstellen können,
den Rest seines Lebens
mit einer Person zu verbringen,
bevor man wirklich
eine seriöse Beziehung eingeht.
Nicht?
Hm ... nein, finde ich nicht.
Hast du vor, bis an dein Lebensende
mit mir zusammenzusein?
Nein,
aber ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Ich kann es mir vorstellen,
aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl ...
Aber wer denn nicht?
Oder wovon sprichst du?
Das ist doch bei vielen so.
Ja.
- Nicht bei allen.
Aber es muss ja auch nicht sein.
Veränderungen im Leben
sind doch auch gut.
Ja, ja.
Ja, okay, du hast recht.
Ja, ja. Aber ...
Hm.
* Stöhnen *
Holy shit.
Wie ein Zug in Graubünden.
- Schau mal, das ist richtig schön.
Sind wir schon in Slowenien?
Gleich.
Wir fahren jetzt über die Grenze.
* Gähnen *
Guten Morgen. Wir sind in Zagreb.
Ah, fuck.
Hä, aber wir sind doch
aus dem ausgestiegen.
Der Typ dort sagte,
wir hätten ihn soeben verpasst.
All right.
Komische Sache.
- What the fuck?
Ey, fuck, wo ist unser Zelt?
- Ich hab's.
Gott sei Dank!
Es ist ... In der Ecke zu sitzen,
macht es nicht einfacher.
* Lachen *
Bin ich dran?
- Seid ihr mit Interrail unterwegs?
Ja, aber eigentlich sind wir
auf Matur... Bin ich dran?
Maturareise?
Ja, die anderen sind mit dem
Flugzeug unterwegs, wir mit dem Zug.
Cool.
Wieso mit dem Zug
und nicht mit dem Flugzeug?
Muss ich das wirklich erklären?
Ich meine, mit der Klasse
reist man doch gemeinsam.
Ich finde es nicht angemessen,
für die Maturareise zu fliegen,
wenn man einen Monat vorher
noch auf den Strassen rumgehüpft ist
und fürs Klima demonstriert hat.
Ich bin so nett.
Du bist so ein Loser.
Das ist mir wirklich egal.
- Strom sparen.
* Hüpfende elektronische Musik *
* Stimmengewirr, Popmusik *
* Fangesang *
Sobald du sagen musst: "Ich muss
mit dieser Person etwas machen,
wir haben uns schon so lange nicht
mehr gesehen", läuft etwas falsch.
Du musst etwas mit ...
Man soll sich mit jemandem treffen
wollen, man muss Lust dazu haben.
Wenn es sich ergibt, dass man sich
nach einem halben Jahr trifft,
umso schöner.
Aber sich zu zwingen, jemanden zu
treffen, auf den man keine Lust hat,
das ist nicht richtig.
(Elias) Lust ist das eine,
aber Zeit ist etwas anderes.
Du musst niemanden treffen.
- Du stellst es als Zwang dar.
Ja, aber am Ende erwartet jeder,
dass man sich mit ihm trifft.
Aber du stellst es als Zwang dar.
(Luca) Einige Leute
habe ich lange nicht gesehen,
sie sind trotzdem meine Freunde.
(Elias) Das meinte ich auch nicht.
Wir haben etwas
aneinander vorbei geredet.
Wir diskutieren das morgen noch mal.
Sicher.
Vielleicht
suche ich zu sehr nach Harmonie.
Ich bin ...
Du bist zwischen ...
Ich bin dazwischen
und finde es schade,
dass nicht alle zueinander finden.
Das verstehe ich.
* Technomusik:
"What Is Love" von Haddaway *
Ja, es ist doch nicht so ...
Ich habe mir vorgestellt,
das sei mitten in der Tundra.
Ja, doch.
Okay, das ...
- Dort ist das Restaurant.
Es gibt sogar einen Bootsanleger.
Es ist nicht einfach,
von den Menschen wegzukommen.
Dort sind so Waschräume.
- Wir sind 7 Std. gefahren.
Und wir sind immer noch
bei den Touristen.
(Englisch)
Ich versuche mal,
ob man das allein aufbauen kann.
Es sollte gehen, bzw.
ich habe es schon mal geschafft.
Kann ich dir helfen?
Weisst du was? Eigentlich ...
Jetzt, wo du fragst.
Jetzt kann man hier ziehen.
Oh!
Nice.
Yeah, oh ja!
- Nicht wahr?
Nicht schlecht.
Irgendwo steht es auf. Oh shit,
hier hat etwas nicht geklappt.
Der Boden ist total steinig.
Wie erlauben die sich,
das als Campingplatz zu vermieten?
Als wären Steine darunter.
- Es sind Steine oder Minen.
Man fühlt sich wie zu Hause.
Yeah!
Nice.
- Nice Sache.
Willkommen.
* Vogelzwitschern, Verkehrslärm *
Das ist 97.
Okay, we're coming closer.
Hier.
Also, unser
"Keine Angst, wir leben"-Chat.
"Angekommen in Cinque Terre."
Schau mal her!
* Fotoklicken *
Nein.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich finde diese noch cool.
Ich finde es schöner,
wenn man es richtig sieht.
Mimimi.
- Na ja!
V.a. waren wir hier wirklich.
- Eine für meine Grosseltern.
Meiner Oma
könnte ich auch schreiben.
Ich habe letzthin
ein Gedicht für Lars geschrieben.
Jö.
Also, ein Lustiges.
"Ich hoffe,
du vermisst mich nicht zu fest."
"Bald bin ich wieder
mit dir im Nest."
In diesem Stil.
Ich glaube, ich mache es wieder so.
Ich muss kreativ sein.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ähm, gehen wir rechts? Dort ist es
vielleicht etwas abgelegener.
Nicht so viele nackte Babys und so.
Hier hat es nicht so viel Sonne,
das ist schade.
Sonne wäre schön.
Dort vorne?
- Gehen wir weiter?
Ich glaube,
dort vorne kommt keine Sonne mehr.
Sonne mit Menschen
oder Schatten ohne Menschen.
Ich bin für Schatten ohne Menschen.
Yummy!
- Guten Appetit!
Frisches NRG-5.
Es lässt sich gut zerbröseln.
Es hatte auch
viel Zeit zum Trocknen.
Wie kann bei so etwas
das Datum ablaufen?
Ich dachte das sei viel länger
haltbar, vielleicht 15 Jahre.
Mit Zimt schmeckt es geil.
Ja. Aber haben wir Zucker
in unserem Gewürzstreuer?
Nein, da ist nur Salziges drin.
Oh, fucking hell.
Ah, fuck.
Was machst du denn da?
Ich versuche nur, warmes NRG-5
zu essen. Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Hm ... lauwarm.
Es ist okay.
Es ist schwierig, die zuzuteilen.
Wer welche bekommt?
- Ja.
Was schreibt man so?
"Hallo, Mutter.
Wir sind da und da ..."
Schreibst du hochdeutsch?
- Nein.
Na dann.
Wie machen wir das am besten?
Es gibt doch so eine coole Technik.
Moment. Man verdreht es irgendwie.
Eine Schlaufe.
- Nein, nein, ein Achterknoten.
Eine Schlaufe
würde auch nicht aufgehen,
mit drei Doppelknoten oder so.
Wenn du sogar Namen für die Knoten
hast, mach du sie doch. - Oh!
Okay, also jetzt kommt
der Spezialknoten von Debbie.
Zack!
Die Schnur hätte höher sein dürfen.
Hm, ja.
Sie wurde etwas runtergezogen.
Wir müssen das noch beschweren.
Z.B. mit Steinen -
davon gibt es hier ja genug!
Ich habe etwas im Auge.
Nice, jetzt können wir
im Regen kochen.
So cool.
- Ja.
Top.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Oder hier?
Hier?
- Hier.
Oh, der Stein ist heiss.
# Before the cool done run out
I'll be giving it my best.
# And nothing's going to stop me
but divine intervention.
# I reckon it's again my turn
to win some or learn some.
# But I won't hesitate no more,
no more.
# It cannot wait, I'm yours.
# There's no need to complicate.
Our time is short.
# This is our fate, I'm yours.
# Du du du du-du,
du-du du-du du-du.
* Applaus *
Do you want to dance?
* Lachen *
Are you inspired?
Oh, so süss!
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Blöd, es ist total nass.
Schau mal, voll die Pfütze.
Wir können nichts machen.
Wir haben es versucht.
Na ja.
Gute Nacht.
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
425, das ist sicher
der hinterste Wagen.
Wo siehst du 425?
- Ich glaube es wirklich nicht.
* Unverständliche
Lautsprecherdurchsage *
Das klingt gut!
Ja, ja.
- Ja, ja!
Mal schauen. Die Lok ist zwar
nicht hier, aber wir schauen mal.
(Englisch)
Um 7 Uhr?
Vom 8. ...
Ist heute der 7., Jungs?
- Ja.
Ihr seid Pfeifen.
Aber er fährt doch am 8.
Aha!
- Er fährt ja am 8.
Nein, nein, schaut mal!
Hier steht, vom 8. auf den 9.
Denn hier auf der rechten Seite
bei "Budapest" steht der 9.
Witzig!
- Nicht wahr?
Der Klassiker:
die falsche Reservierung.
Bekommen sie noch einen Schlafplatz?
Deborah und Arthur
finden in der nächsten Folge
endlich die erträumte Wildnis.
So ein schönes Land.
- Das beste, in dem ich je war.
Das ist Freiheit.
Die vier Freunde müssen waschen.
Hast du je schon
etwas im Internet gesucht?
Ach, komm!
- Du bist so eine Pfeife.
Und Maya und Francesca erwartet
in Barcelona eine böse Überraschung.
Erst wenn wir weg sind, sagen wir
unseren Eltern, dass wir hier waren.
Erst wenn es uns gut geht.